les auteurs compositeurs chanteurs ne
sont pas forcément des imposteurs qui
c'est monsieur parfois il faut se taire
moi je veux voir o'shea sur un poster
il faut des jambes
les gens
on a reçu grand corps malade évidemment
en aparté il vous adore la preuve avec
ce que c'était c'était une super
revanche c'était un super cadeau d'avoir
ce titre là ce clip là il veut voir sur
un poster il y a eu à fabien lecoeuvre
ce chroniqueur effectivement qui
critiquent votre physique qui lui
n'avait pas très envie de voir se
forment au ster métro est aussi grand
corps malade qui qui lui j'allais dire
voilà qui lui claque la porte au nez
ouais bien même franchement avec élan
c'est vrai mais il avait adoré son album
à grand corps malade est ce quelqu'un
que j'admire beaucoup depuis toujours
d'ailleurs depuis que j'ai entendu ces
morceaux et quand j'aurai attendu ce
morceau j'étais tellement émue en fait
j'avais trop envie de réagir en musique
avec tout ce qui s'était dit avec fabien
lecoeuvre voilà mais en fait moi je
savais pas quoi dire en fait parce que
j'ai rien demandé et je voulais pas
parler de moi même de mon physique
c'était trop bizarre reflète et du coup
j'ai trouvé ça hyper hyper classe et
façon c'est quelqu'un de très classe est
très talentueux et ouais franchement
cela d'or quoi et même du clip qui l'a
fait être super intelligent